[Music]
let me start with a curious question can
anyone tell me how many elections will
be held in 2024 around the world we're
talking about General Regional and
Municipal elections any idea well we're
talking about 76 elections no more and
no less polls in India Pakistan Russia
Mexico Brazil as well as the European
Parliament elections will call for half
of the world's population to vote
however I think if there is one thing we
can all agree on it is that there is one
eltion that stands out above all others
of course I'm talking about the
presidential election in the United
States of America an election that could
end with the return of Donald Trump to
the White House right now it is not the
most likely but it could happen
inflation and above all age are taking
their toll on Joe Biden's popularity in
fact according to a recent Washington
Post poll 63% of Americans do not
believe Biden is fit to face a second
term but visual politic Community this
time we are not going to tell you about
President Biden today we put the
spotlight light on none other than the
figure who accompanied him to Victory
vice president Camala
Harris because if you think Biden's
popularity is low that's because you
haven't seen Harris's ratings in
particular in news stories like this
column kamla Harris the incredible
disappearing vice president the most
unknown vice president in living memory
has become a cause for serious concern
within the Democratic party leadership
it is for one simple reason they need
everything to be or at least appear to
be perfect to prevent Trump from
returning to the Oval Office and this is
where vice president Kamala Harris plays
a particularly important role but why
isn't the main role supposed to be that
of presidential candidate Joe Biden why
do many already see Harris as crucial to
another Democratic Victory disclaimer if
many of you don't know Cala Harris I
don't blame you she's been looking more
like a ghost than a vice president of
the United States for a while now but
with this video all that's about to
change let's get
started
[Music]
Kamala breaking
barriers Kamala Harris is one of those
people whose profile seems predestined
for big Washington Politics the daughter
of an Indian cancer researcher and a
Jamaican Economist she began breaking
barriers early on as early as 1990 she
began working at the San Francisco
District Attorney's office after
graduating from the University of
California law school during her eight
years in that office Cala began to build
a reputation as a tough woman her work
at the time focused on fighting gang
violence drug trafficking and child
sexual abuse however that would only be
the beginning of an extremely fruitful
career you see having achieved a certain
reputation in the city of San Francisco
in 2004 she became the district attorney
during this time her reputation as a
tough woman was enhanced after the
conviction rate in the district
skyrocketed during her first 3 years
perhaps that is why in 2010 she was
elected Attorney General of the state
State of California the first woman and
the first African-American to hold that
position well it was just at this point
when she achieved National notoriety
especially thanks to becoming one of the
main voices against Proposition 8 which
banned same-sex marriages and not only
that in 2012 she accomplished one of her
biggest accomplishments a$2 billion
settlement for Californians whose homes
had been foreclosed upon after being
victims of practices deemed unfair by
mortgage lenders prior to 2007 so
naturally following such a victory her
name began to spread like wildfire
within the Democratic party and finally
in 2016 focusing on issues such as
abortion raising the minimum wage and
reforming the judicial system she became
senator for the most popular state in
the United States California she was the
first indianamerican woman and the
second black woman in the history of the
Senate and it was in this chamber that
Camala Harris made the ultimate leap
into the world of big politics she did
it by asking her opponents in the
hearings very incisive
questions of course with her popularity
On The Rise her political aspirations
would not be limited to the Senate and
in 2019 she announced her campaign to
win the Democratic party's nomination in
the 2020 presidential election Harris
wanted to become Trump's rival however
the lack of funding and a series of
mistakes made during the campaign meant
her star which had started out strong in
the primaries eventually faded even so
Joe Biden after being named Democratic
candidate and perhaps after the conflict
and tension produced by the
assassination of George Floyd made this
decision Joe Biden's vice president pick
Cara Harris and so finally after Trump's
defeat in 2020 on 20th of January 2021
Harris became the first woman
African-American and of Indian origin to
hold the position of Vice President of
the United States at the time many saw
her as the clear heir to Biden however
these last 3 years have been a complete
slowdown for Harris's Stella career so
absent that today many are wondering who
the hell is Camala Harris so the
question is what the heck happened well
let's take a
look Harris in
Decline let's be fair there are a few
cases in which US vice presidents have
stood out few very few have managed to
be remembered after a few years however
with Camala Harris there had been
expectations that this would not be the
case there was an expectation of a 180°
turnaround in the vice presidency it was
thought that she would have great
presence within the government but
unfortunately for her that has not been
the case Harris came to Washington
thinking that she would be the new Dick
Cheney pulling strings at will and ended
up being more like Selena mayor if you
haven't seen vep I don't know what
you're waiting for unlike some former
Democratic vice presidents like Al Gore
under Bill Clinton or Joe Biden under
Barack Obama or even Republican Dick
Cheney under George Bush Jr who managed
to have quite a bit of influence in the
executive Harris has not been able to
get her own voice yet many analysts
argue that Harris has strictly complied
with what is normally expected of a vice
president which is nothing more than not
overshadowing the
president traditionally the position of
Vice has been neither the most brilliant
nor a great springboard in fact in the
last 50 years only two vice presidents
were later elected President George Bush
Senior and Joe Biden him self well there
was also Gerard Ford who came to the
overal office on the rebound so for many
the absence is not so strange it's quite
normal viewed from this perspective
Kamala could have fulfilled what is
expected of the position in fact despite
that apparent absence Cala has been key
to the Biden Administration repeatedly
especially in the Senate where she has
broken quite a few ties kamla Harris
breaks record of tiebreaking votes in
the Senate the vice president has
provided the decisive vote of the Senate
32 two times in a reflection of
Democrats narrow majority and broader
polarization in politics in fact her
tiebreaking vote was absolutely decisive
in moving forward one of the Biden
administration's major measures the $2
trillion post-pandemic economic stimulus
plan once more she has also managed to
get all of President Biden's nominees
confirmed in both Congress and the
Senate something that has been key to
moving the administration's agenda
forward and if that wen't enough Harris
has played a larger role in the White
House foreign policy than might appear
at first glance for example in these 3
years she has visited almost 20
countries and met with more than 100
world leaders in fact Harris was not
only instrumental in normalizing
diplomatic relations with France in 2021
but was also the one who in early 2022
warned zalinski of the impending Russian
invasion of Ukraine however all this
activity has come to nothing compared to
the public perception of her being
missing and the barrage of critic I ISM
she has received since her appointment
and for many this poor political
performance has had a lot to do with her
[Music]
ambition for example just 6 months after
taking on the vice presidency she was
criticized for not wanting to visit the
southern border directly to push for
measures to alleviate the immigration
crisis let's just say that Camala Harris
didn't want to taint herself with those
issues then after her resounding failure
in her interview with NBC's Lester Holt
to explain the situation confident in
her plummeted by November 2021 her
approval rating stood at just 28% making
hers one of the most unpopular Vice
presidencies in history on top of that
Harris has also been dogged by
accusations of allegedly creating an
extremely toxic work environment around
her bordering on harassment and many
linked this situation to the resignation
of key members of her team during the
first year and a half of her tenure to
make matters worse Harris has had some
particularly embarrassing moments at
public events where nonsensical iCal
phrases have gone viral which of course
the opposition has exploited in order to
ridicule her and all of this explains
why Harris's approval rating throughout
2023 stood at just 32% however in recent
months her team and she herself have set
a goal to relaunch Her Image in the face
of a key issue in the 2024 elections
President Biden's Advanced age listen
up the Democrat
key
at the end of April 2023 Biden finally
announced his decision to run for
reelection alongside him as expected
wood stand Cala Harris the problem is
that if this happens the election
campaign will be dominated by a very
specific issue Joe Biden's age you see
if reelected Biden would become the
oldest president- elect in the history
of the country at 82 so many already
doubt the real ability of the current
president to complete a second term that
would theoretically end at a whopping 86
years precisely for this reason all the
spotlights are this time fixed on Kamal
Harris in fact the Republican party is
already saying it loud and clear a vote
for President Biden is a vote for
president Harris and that is exactly the
same reason Harris and her team have
been working hard in recent months to
try to improve public perception of one
of the most unpopular Vice presidencies
in history of course this is not
entirely
new it was as early as June 2022 when
Harris saw an opportunity to relaunch
Her Image again after the Supreme
Court's overturning of Ro v Wade which
resulted in the elimination of the right
to abortion that the court itself had
upheld for the past 50 years well the
vice president became one of the main
voices against this decision and ended
up being crucial in exploiting this case
in favor of the Democrats that improved
Her Image but it was not enough that's
why in the last year she has been
touring different universities around
the country to consolidate the youth
vote with an agenda focused on issues
such as abortion the environment and
LGBT rights at the same time Harris has
been raising her more combative aspect
again and the truth is that the data
seem to indicate the plan is working Her
Image within the Democratic party has
improved and many lobbies seem to be
betting on her again Paris gets her
Cavalry top groups to spend $10 million
plus to boost her EMILY's List has big
plans to defend the vice president
before the election haris absolutely the
best choice for Biden running mate
Newsome once more it's not just that
Harris is improving Her Image but that
this time history may be on her side if
Republicans insist on attacking her
however Harris cannot claim victory so
easily despite all her efforts her
popularity level is still at rock bottom
and to top it all off the vice president
carries a deep stain the immigration
crisis on the border with
Mexico you see since the arrival of
Biden and Harris in the White House in
2021 the number of encounters with
immigrants at the border with Mexico has
been growing exponentially surpassing
the record levels of more than 20 years
ago in fact between October and December
2023 alone 730,000 migrants were
apprehended right at the border with
Mexico and of course new stories like
this indicates that the pressure only
seems to be increasing massive migrant
Caravan heading to us Mexico border is a
largest in over a year may balloon to up
to 15,000 people activist warns the
office of the vice president who has
been responsible for immigration policy
in the Biden Administration has tried to
address this crisis by focusing on the
major source of this massive migration
the so-called Northern
triangle the northern triangle refers to
the area comprising Guatemala Honduras
and El Salvador we've already told you
here on visual politic on several
occasions about the harsh living
conditions that exist in these countries
poverty lack of security corruption it
is not surprising that it is one of the
main sources of immigrants to the United
States well vice president Harris has
promoted the so-called us strategy to
address the root causes of Central
American migration a strategy endowed
with 4.2 billion public and private
dollars which seeks to improve living
conditions in these three countries in
order to discourage immigration on top
of that the Biden Administration has
also held several meetings with Mexican
president amlo to further engage Mexico
and has strengthened funding for border
security yet it seems clear that these
measures for the time being are not
having any effect among other things
because changing the socioeconomic
reality of several countries is a
multi-year process and because the
execution of the plan does not seem to
have been the best either once more
Americans want quick results in the face
of what has become nothing short of one
of their greatest
[Music]
concerns this immigration crisis along
with the inflation crisis are by far the
two biggest assets for Donald Trump's
aspiration ations to take the White
House and they are largely what explains
news like this Trump leads in five
critical States as voters blast Biden
times Sienna poll finds load to Biden as
poll shows Trump in lead for 2024
presidential election Trump ahead 47% to
43% worrying some Democrats as others
caution avoiding mad po disease so you
see Camala Harris the vice president who
came in Breaking All the barriers may
come to play a key role in the
reelection she has the youth and
potential energy that Biden May lack
after a difficult start and the debacle
of her political image Harris wants to
regain ground in order to achieve the
most coveted goal of all Washington
politicians the Oval Office but at this
point it's time to hear from all of you
do you think Harris is the real key to
democratic reelection how could the
current Administration deal with the
severe immigration crisis at the
southern border will this crisis be the
one that propels Trump back into the
presidency you can leave me your answers
in the comments and as always don't
forget the h on visual politic we
release new videos every week so
subscribe to this channel hit the little
bell so you don't miss any of our
updates if you like the video like it
I'll see you in the next one all the
best see you next
time